[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE KLEIDERMACHER: Hello,
and welcome to the Android P
edition of what's new
in Android security.
My name is Dave.
I lead mobile security
here at Google.
And in a few minutes,
I'll hand it over
to Xiaowen, who is the lead
security product manager
for the Android platform.
We have a lot of
ground to cover,
so we'll start with a brief
state of the union on Android
security, and then jump into
all the really cool things
we've been working on in Android
security over the past year
and launching here at Android
P, including secure hardware
support advancements, lock
screen authentication,
integrity, and privacy.
So state of the union.
Let's talk a little bit about
what the Android security
strategy looks like.
There are really
three main pillars.
First, Google Play Protect.
This is the malware protection
and mobile security services
that run on over 2 billion
Android devices today.
The second pillar is
platform engineering.
These are the core
operating system defenses
that we build into Android to
improve security to systems,
such as SELinux, control-flow
integrity protection, which
we've been investing in a
lot in P, and encryption,
verified boot, lots
of other features.
The third pillar is the
security development lifecycle.
These are all the programs
that we put in place
to ensure a consistent,
high-quality level for security
across the Android ecosystem.
So this includes things like
testing infrastructures,
and also includes our
security patching programs.
We've been working
really hard on that.
A couple of things
we are investing in,
we've been trying to make
Android just easier to patch.
So Google, we have a
pretty steady track record
for years now every single
month delivering those patches
to the market.
But we want to make sure that
all Android OEMs are delivering
patches regularly
to their devices
as well, not just
Google's devices.
And so making Android more
modular like with projects
like Treble really help
contribute to that.
We've also worked on building
security patching into our OEM
agreements.
Now, this will really
lead to a massive increase
in the number of
devices and users
receiving regular
security patches.
So we're really
excited about that.
But there are a couple
of also really important
philosophical principles
that underlie everything
we do when it comes to security.
We believe in
transparency and openness,
because that breeds confidence
and it breeds trust.
Conversely, a closed platform,
secrecy, that breeds distrust.
But actually, there's a really
important security advantage
to be open.
Today's mobile devices are
faced with really sophisticated
attack threats.
When you have billions of users,
it's an attractive target.
And so it deserves the
strongest possible defense.
With a closed
platform, the defenders
are the employees of the one
company that owns the platform.
But with Android, we have
the thousands of Googlers
that wake up every
morning thinking
about how best to protect
users and our platforms.
We have the device manufacturers
who have their own security
team to work closely
with Google on protecting
Android and its users.
We have the microprocessor
manufacturers--
Arm, Intel, Qualcomm,
Broadcom, and others,
also with their security teams
helping to protect Android.
We have the worldwide
open-source Linux community
contributing to Android
security every day.
We have the academic
research community,
which simply prefer
working on open platforms.
So this is a mass force
multiplier in protection.
And as operating systems have
matured, the power of open
has really become
evident to the point
where today, the protective
capabilities of Android
are now on par with any
other mobile platform.
And I strongly believe
that the power of open
will accelerate those
protective capabilities
for our users going forward.
The other really
important philosophy
that underlies our
strategy is measurability.
We always look for objective
independent measurements
to help not only
inform the work that we
do to ensure we're investing
in the right directions,
but also to measure progress.
And so one example you
see here is the incidence
of malware or Potentially
Harmful Applications
we call PHA on devices.
The bottom curve are devices
that load only from Play,
and the top curve
are devices that load
from sources other than Play.
And you can see over time, it's
been reducing across all users.
So we are committed
to protecting users,
regardless of where they
get their applications from.
But this improvement
is due to many things.
It's locking down APIs
and permissions over time.
We're constantly
looking at that.
And it's investing in
the malware detection
engine itself.
Today, 60% of
malware is detected
through machine learning.
And that's been one area
of big investment for us.
Over the past year, we've had
a 50% reduction in PHA on Play.
And so we're really
happy with the progress,
but certainly, we're not content
with where we stand today.
Although, I will say that the
odds of loading a PHA from Play
is about the same as
being struck by lightning.
So it is a safe place to
live on your mobile life,
but we're going to continue
to invest tremendously
in this area.
Another really
important measurement
is the overall ability
of the operating system
to protect itself
against exploitation.
In any complex product,
there are going to be bugs.
But there's no reason
why bugs have to lead
to exploitation to harm users.
And so we work really
hard on building
features and
improvements that make
Android much more difficult
and expensive to exploit.
So how do you measure
how well you're doing?
Well, lots of people want
to purchase exploits.
There's a vibrant
market for that.
And as exploits get more
difficult, of course,
the law of supply demand, the
prices are going to go up.
And so we watch the
pricing over time.
And there's a number
of different markets
you can look at.
On the left-hand side, you
see the device manufacturers
rewards programs.
So the green bars are
Google's rewards programs,
which now are paying
out the highest
rewards in the industry.
Another market you can look at
are the elite hacking contests,
like Mobile Pwn2Own.
And you can see on the
graph on the right,
the price of Android
exploits has risen each year
to the point where now this
is the most recent event
a few months ago.
The pricing for Android is
on par with other platforms.
And if you haven't
seen the results,
Android performed quite
well in that event.
Another market is
the gray market.
It's independent
researchers and brokers
who will sell exploits
to the highest bidder.
This market is a little
bit harder to track,
but we have connections to a
lot of researchers out there.
And again, anecdotally,
what we're seeing
is the price of
exploitation on Android
is now as high or higher
than any other platform.
So this is really great.
We're happy with the
progress, but we continue
to invest in all these areas.
And now let's switch
gears and talk about some
of the new emerging
features in Android P,
starting with the feature called
Android Protected Confirmation.
So the problem here is in
today's secure mobility,
we use mobile devices for much
more than we ever did before,
much more critical things.
But there's still
a ceiling of trust
that we haven't
quite broken through.
We don't vote for prime minister
or president from our phones.
We don't program life-critical
medical devices like an insulin
pump from our phones.
We don't have our passports
built into our phones.
It is our goal to break
through that ceiling,
and Android Protected
Confirmation
is a bold step in
that direction.
I'll talk about
a few use cases--
medical, financial, enterprise.
But the key innovation here
is Protected Confirmation
is the first time in any
major operating system API
that we now have the ability to
execute a high-assurance user
transaction completely within
secure hardware running
in a Trusted
Execution Environment,
or TEE, that runs separate
from the main operating system.
So how does it work?
So an application developer, say
you're a medical company that's
developing a solution
for people with diabetes,
and so you're managing
an insulin pump.
You want to inject two insulin
units into your insulin pump.
And the application
will enable the user
to select two insulin units,
and then call the protection
API to transmit that data
to the secure hardware area
where a completely
independent trusted user
interface will execute.
The interface you see
here on the screen
shows the two insulin units.
The user then confirms
it by pressing a button.
The input is guarded
in this protected area.
And then this entire
transaction is
signed using a
cryptographic key that
never leaves that secure area.
This provides higher assurance
to the relying party,
whether it be an insulin
pump, or a financial service,
or enterprise that the integrity
of this data was not corrupted.
Even if you had
root level malware,
you cannot corrupt the
integrity of that transaction.
So in code, this is really easy.
We use the standard
Android KeyStore
API to create a public key.
We have this new method to set
the flag confirmation required.
We create the dialog for the
confirmation dialog using
the Confirmation Dialog API.
And then we simply call
the present prompt method
to transfer control
from the main Android OS
to this trusted execution
environment, where
the user will then interact
with that special screen.
Really easy.
So we have a number
of launch partners
who've been working
really closely with us
on this technology.
They've been building
prototypes that they
intend to make product into
a product in the future.
So Bigfoot Biomedical
is a firm that
works on solutions for
people with diabetes.
And you see here an app,
the Bigfoot Biomedical app.
The user is looking at the
glucose level and deciding,
I want to inject 1
and 1/2 insulin units.
Uses the app to
select that, then
calls the API to
invoke the new user
interface that you see there.
The user confirms.
And then, and only then,
will the insulin pump
administer that dose.
In the medical side,
we have Royal Bank
of Canada, RBC, that is
working to integrate Protected
Confirmations into
their application.
I don't have a
video for this one,
but you can track left to right.
This application is moving
a person-to-person financial
transfer.
We see we're going to send
$1,500 to [? Robbie. ?]
The application invokes
the Protected Conformations
API, which you
see in the middle.
The user confirms $1,500.
So $1,500 can't be
changed to $15,000.
The relying party
on the other end
has high confidence
that indeed, we
intended to send
[? Robbie ?] $1,500,
and the transaction
goes through.
Duo Security is a firm that's
working on strong enterprise
authentication.
Imagine you're logging
into your Chromebook,
into your G Suite application,
and it launches a second factor
authentication to your phone.
You see the request
come in on the left.
The Duo Security
application comes up
and asks for confirmation,
but then there's
the second level confirmation
using the Protected
Confirmation API that
provides, again, a higher
level of assurance for
the enterprise that it
is the device, and user,
and location that's expected
for that authentication.
So there are a lot of
other launch partners
we've worked closely
with on this.
Insulet Corporation is also
integrating their application
for control of diabetes.
ProxToMe is doing
proximal-based authentication.
Nok Nok Labs in the enterprise
authentication space as well.
I'd also like to throw
a shout-out to Qualcomm.
We've been working really
closely with Qualcomm
to integrate the Protected
Conformations API
into the next generation
Qualcomm chipsets.
Because Protected Conformations
requires a deep integration
at the hardware level,
it is optional for P,
and so it requires a
supported Android P device.
We're breaking through that
last ceiling of assurance
in mobility, so
it's very exciting.
There's a lot more
to talk about,
and so I'd like to
now call up Xiaowen
to take us through the story.
[APPLAUSE]
XIAOWEN XIN: Thanks, Dave.
Good morning, everyone.
And I'm really
excited to be here
to talk about a lot more of the
security and privacy features
that we've built into Android
P. So as Dave mentioned,
secure hardware is a
huge focus area for us,
because they can provide
defenses against attacks
that software alone is simply
not sufficient to handle.
And so Protected
Confirmation was
an API that really
leveraged secure hardware.
And another feature that
we're making in Android P,
it leverages secure
hardware also
to provide stronger
protection for private keys.
So why do we need stronger
protection for private keys?
Well, Google Pay transit
is a great example here.
And in fact, we're
working closely with them
on this P feature,
and they're going
to launch with it
later this year.
Consider their security goal.
In the traditional
transit use case,
they need to make sure that
your transit card and only
your credit card can be used
to pay for your bus ride.
So your transit card has
your account information,
a lot of secrets in there
that represents your account.
Now, the transit
cards are simply
made using a secure
element inside of it,
so it's very hard to break into
it, extract secrets out of it,
and duplicate that card.
So Android Pay transit is now
working to replace that transit
card with your phone.
And so we need to make sure that
we provide the same security
guarantees, which is that your
secrets cannot be extracted out
of your phone and put
onto another phone.
So in order to pay
for your bus ride,
you must present your phone.
And a great solution here
is to use secure hardware.
Now, Google Pay
transit is one example
of an in-person transaction.
Payments is another.
In all of these
use cases, you want
to make sure that your
phone and only your phone
can make that transaction.
There are quite a
few other examples
where we benefit from stronger
protection for private keys.
For example, if you have
high value cloud data,
if you're an
enterprise, or if you
are a financial
institution, you want
to make sure that all
requests, all data access
is coming from a known phone,
a phone that you trust.
And that phone is
identified by a private key.
Also, if you have
high-value local data,
let's say your password manager,
you're storing passwords
locally on disk,
then you may want
to encrypt it again with
a private key that's
well-protected.
And so how do we provide
stronger protection?
Traditionally, secure elements
such as those built [INAUDIBLE]
smartcard credit cards, and
second factor security keys
and credit cards, are the gold
standard for hardware security.
They're built to
exacting standards,
and certified by
professional labs
to be resistant to
hardware tampering.
And phones are now starting to
incorporate that exact hardware
directly into the phone
so that your phone can
replace your transit card,
replace your credit card,
and replace your second
factor security key.
And so with Android P,
we're now exposing APIs
so that all the
applications on Android
can take advantage of this type
of temporariness and hardware
on compatible devices
and potentially enable
brand new use cases.
Specifically, we're
adding a new type
of KeyStore called StrongBox.
StrongBox is built using a
tamper-resistant hardware,
like a secure element,
that has isolated CPU, RAM,
and secure storage.
The fact that it has
its own dedicated
CPU and RAM is pretty
important, because it makes it
so that it's resistant to
shared resource attacks.
For example, many of the
high profile hardware
attacks that we've
heard about recently,
StrongBox is resistant
to those, as well as
resistant to side
channel attacks,
like timing attacks, as
well as physical attacks,
like glitching the power line.
So when we look at the
KeyStore types that
are available on
Android, there are now
three types of KeyStore.
On older Android
devices, KeyStore
was typically implemented using
the Android operating system
directly.
On new Android devices that ship
with Android Nougat and above,
KeyStore was implemented using
the TE, the Trusted Execution
Environment.
And now with Android P, we're
providing a new KeyStore
called StrongBox that can
run alongside it together
with the existing
KeyStore and the TE.
StrongBox is resistant to the
widest variety of attacks,
and is really
well-suited if you have
a use case that requires
strong protection
for your private keys.
Now, the caveat here
is that because it
does require new
hardware, StrongBox
will be available on
only some new devices
that ship with Android P.
To use StrongBox, it's
fairly straightforward.
When you create
your KeyStore key,
set a new flag to request that
the key be backed by StrongBox.
If the device
supports StrongBox,
then everything
succeeds and goes well.
If the device does
not support StrongBox,
you'll get a StrongBox
unavailable exception.
So to summarize,
StrongBox is implemented
using tamper-resistant
hardware, like a secure element.
Secure elements are the gold
standard for hardware security,
and this is the
first time that we're
offering a generic API to access
this type of secure hardware
for key management.
This feature, as well as the
Protected Conformation API,
are really pushing the boundary
for secure hardware support
on mobile.
And we're really excited
about the use cases
that this enables.
So protecting your
private keys is
one thing that apps need to do.
Another thing that
apps often need to do
is to make sure that the
right user is present.
When you look at a typical
Android device, especially
one that's up to date
and fully patched,
the most likely
security incident
to happen to that
device is not malware,
but rather getting
lost or stolen.
And so a lock screen is
very important for Android.
Make sure you set a lock screen.
And also, as an
app developer, make
sure that you do gate-sensitive
access on user presence,
on user authentication.
So in Android P, we added
a few different features
to help app developers
do that, starting
with keyguard-bound keys.
Keyguard-bound keys
are KeyStore keys
that are well-suited
for protecting
very sensitive data that you
store directly on the device.
Like the name implies,
keyguard-bound keys
have their functionality
tied to the keyguard, which
is the lock screen on Android.
And so these keys can be used
to encrypt data at any time,
and can be used to
decrypt data only
when the device is unlocked.
And so the lifecycle
of these keys
are tied to the lifecycle
of the lock screen.
For example, if you have
very sensitive, very
confidential enterprise
data or very private
health and fitness
data, you might
want to encrypt it with
a keyguard-bound key
before you store it to disk,
so that if that device does
get lost or stolen,
as long as there's
a lock screen on that device,
it's now a little bit harder
for an attacker to access
the sensitive data.
To use a keyguard-bound
key, it's
also fairly straightforward.
When you create
your KeyStore key,
set a flag to require that
the device be unlocked
to use it for decryption.
Then when you create
your cipher objects,
you can create it for
encryption at any time.
And you can create
it for decryption
only when the
device is unlocked.
So fairly straightforward,
fairly simple.
Now, what if your
device has been properly
unlocked, but you want to check
for user authentication one
more time, let's say, before
a very sensitive action
like a payment happens?
This is where
BiometricPrompt comes in.
BiometricPrompt
is our replacement
for FingerprintManager.
Now, a lot of apps today
are using FingerprintManager
to reauthenticate the user using
fingerprints one more time.
Now, FingerprintManager
had a few limitations.
One is it only works
for fingerprint.
A lot of devices today are
starting to support face, iris,
and other biometric modalities.
And so with BiometricPrompt,
we do support
more than just fingerprint.
We support several
different modalities.
And it will automatically
pick the right modality
for that user and
for that device.
Another benefit
of BiometricPrompt
is that it uses
a standard system
UI, which is really nice from
a user experience perspective
to show the user a standard
UI when they're making
a security-relevant decision.
Also, it sets us up well for
future advances in sensor
technology when you have,
for example, an end display
fingerprint sensor.
It's much easier for
the OEM to customize
this UI to tell the user exactly
where to put their finger,
and less scalable
for an app to have
to create device-specific UI.
We know that
BiometricPrompt is quite
different from
FingerprintManager.
And so to ease the
pain of migration,
we're also providing
a support library.
And so apps will be able to
call the one API in that support
library, and that will use
biometric prompt on Android P
devices, and fall
back gracefully
to FingerprintManager
on older devices.
To use BiometricPrompts,
create the builder object,
and pass it, the
title, and subtitle
in these kinds of properties.
Then call the
authenticate method
on the prompt to create to
show the authentication prompt.
We do recommend that you
pass in the crypto object,
because that's how you tie
successful authentication
attempts to a subsequent
cryptographic operational.
All right, so biometric
prompt works really well
when your users
try to authenticate
your native Android app.
Now, what if the users actually
go into your website in Chrome?
How do you authenticate
them there?
This is where a WebAuthn
and FIDO2 come in.
Coming later this year
in Q4, Chrome on Android
will support
WebAuthn, which means
if the user's going
to your website,
they can now use
their lock screen
or their biometric signals to
authenticate to your website.
And I think this is very
useful because, for example,
if you like to buy
things on the web,
PayPal now actually has
a demo running where
you can use your fingerprints
to authenticate to PayPal
and use that to
make your purchase.
And so that's a
lot more convenient
than typing in your
password every time
you go to PayPal to make
a purchase on the web.
So then to summarize the
several different methods
that we talked about to gate
access based on authentication.
First, with
keyguard-bound keys, you
can tie data access to the
lifecycle of the lock screen.
If the user has already
unlocked the screen
and you want to
reauthenticate the user,
then you can use BiometricPrompt
to show the system
UI to prompt for biometric.
And finally, if that user is
going to your website instead
of your native app,
you can use WebAuthn
to authenticate the
user via fingerprint
in Chrome on Android.
OK, now that you've determined
it's the right user,
let's switch gears one more
time to talk about integrity.
A lot of apps really
need to ensure
the integrity of
their data as well
as the integrity of the device
that they're running on.
So how do we do this?
In Android P, to
help you protect
the integrity of
your data in transit,
we're going to require
TLS by default.
So for all new apps that
target the P API level,
the system will
throw an exception
if the app sends
data in the clear.
Using TLS should be a
no-brainer for apps today,
because it protects the
privacy of your users,
and it also protects
your content
from being modified in
transit, whether it's
injection of unwanted ads,
or injection of tracking
identifiers, or
especially formatted data
to exploit a
weakness in your app.
So you should always encrypt.
Now, if you're connecting to
a legacy website that has not
migrated to TLS yet,
then you can still
opt out of specific domains by
updating your network security
config.
So do visit the
website on this slide
to learn more about customizing
TLS enforcement for your app.
Now, before you run off
to change your code,
we have one more
piece of good news.
A lot of apps care about FIPS
cryptographic compliance,
because it's really
important and regulated
industries and the government.
So we're really
happy that BoringSSL,
which is used to secure
SSL traffic on Android,
recently received CAVP
certificates from NIST
for many FIPS-approved
algorithms.
And so this means that
developers targeting
regulated industries
now basically
have automatic FIPS
compliance built in.
So we're very
excited about that.
All right, so another topic
in the integrity section
that developers
often care about is,
how do I make sure
that the device itself
has not been tampered with?
The device itself
is still healthy?
In Android O, we introduced a
feature called key attestation.
And it's been updated in Android
P. Key attestation allows
you to get a signed
statement directly
from the hardware itself,
from StrongBox, from TE
about the state of the device
and about the properties
of your private keys.
So for example, key
attestation can tell you
whether the device passed
verified boot, whether it's
running a recent security patch,
whether the private keys are
protected by TE or StrongBox.
Another thing that key
attestation will return to you
on compatible
devices on Android P
is the firmware hash that
the device is running.
So this is the digest
of the operating system
that you're running
at this time.
Think of this as
transparency-enabled verified
boot.
What this means
is that if you're
running a firmware digest
that's the same as that
of a known good
version, then you're
actually running a bit
for bit identical version
of the operating system
as a known good version.
So that's a really
powerful thing
to know about what
you're running.
And it's really important for a
tightly controlled environment,
like enterprises, to know
that the operating system
that you're running is an exact
copy of a known good version.
For users of the
SafetyNet attestation API,
the implementation of that
will call the platform
key attestation
API under the hood.
So you [? would ?] be able
to take advantage of this
without any changes
to your code.
Now, in some cases, if you
want to get more information
from the API than what's
returned by SafetyNet,
you can still call the key
attestation API directly.
Now, last, but certainly
not least, privacy.
Privacy is an important
area to security.
We actually talked about
privacy quite a bit
already when we talked
about, for example,
the TLS by default
feature coming in Android.
But there are a few
other privacy features
that are in Android P
that we want to cover now.
First, this is probably one of
my favorite features, sensor
access only in the foreground.
Running on an Android P device,
regardless of your API level,
if your app is in the
background and idle,
you will no longer be able to
access the camera, microphone,
or sensors.
This behavior now is
slightly different
based on the exact
characteristics of the API
that you're targeting.
So for example, with
the microphone API,
you will get
silence when you try
to access a microphone from
the background in idle.
With the camera
API, it will behave
as if you were preempted by a
higher priority camera client.
With sensors, it depends on
whether the sensor returns data
continuously or via callback.
The bottom line is
that if your app is
in the background and
idle, you can no longer
access user data from sensors.
Now, if you need to access the
camera, microphone, or sensors
and you're in the background,
create a foreground service
with a persistent user
visible notification.
So that gives users a lot more
control and more transparency
into which apps have access
to their sensors at that time.
To start a foreground
service, create
that persistent
notification first, and then
call the startForeground method,
and pass in that notification.
All right, besides restricted
background access to sensors,
we've also added a lot more
user control over your data.
So Android is the
first major operating
system to have DNS over
TLS support built right in.
And so your DNS queries will
be redirected to a trusted
resolver of your choice.
That means that third
parties on the web
can no longer monitor or
manipulate your DNS traffic.
Now, if your default DNS
resolver already supports it,
then we will automatically
encrypt your data.
We did this in collaboration
with Alphabet's jigsaw team,
who are working on many other
initiatives in this area.
And so we're really
looking forward
to many new developments here.
Another cool feature
that we added
an Android P in the privacy
space is lockdown mode.
So lockdown mode
is useful if you're
in a situation where
you may temporarily
lose access to your device.
Let's say you need to hand
it over for inspection
at a security checkpoint.
So at that time, you
can put your device
into lockdown mode,
which is now in a state
where only your knowledge
factor, your pinpad
and password can be used
to unlock the device.
And so your fingerprint
and other biometrics
will be disabled.
Your Smart Lock
In fact, notifications will no
longer show on the lock screen.
So you would now have
much higher assurances
on the state of the lock
screen, on the security
of a lock screen when the device
is temporarily out of sight.
So that was a quick overview
of the features that
are coming with Android P.
There's a lot more that we
didn't have time to cover.
And so please do
give us your feedback
at google.com/io/schedule.
And send us an email,
security@android.com.
Thank you for coming,
and have a great day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]